next question today condemning Democrats
retake the Senate in 2020 this is a good
topic to discuss we've only talked about
this a little bit but now that it's
getting closer I want to address it
again and most of the discussion about
2020 is about the White House and
there's the presumption that Democrats
can keep if not extend control of the
House of Representatives but the Senate
is a really interesting body to look at
and unfortunately the answer is that
Democrats almost definitely cannot take
the Senate in 2020
now it's mathematically possible it's
mathematically possible for Democrats to
take the Senate in 2020 Republicans
control it right now
53 to 47 so Democrats need plus three
and the White House because the vice
president becomes the tie-breaking vote
or if Donald Trump is reelected
Democrats need plus four in order to
take control of the Senate now if you
look just at the numbers hey 33 seats
plus the special election for John
McCain's seat are up Democrats are only
down three and there's 34 total seats
that are available the problem is for
Democrats that of those seats that are
up in 2020 Republicans are defending 22
of them meaning that if Democrats hold
all of their seats there are actually
only 22 not 34 seats that they could
take from Republicans most of those 22
are safe Republican seats so when you
get right down to it the opportunity for
Democrats is basically Colorado
Republican Cory Gardner is vulnerable in
Colorado Susan Collins in Maine that's a
possibility that would be two beyond
that it gets really tough I mean okay
you can talk about Joni Ernst in Iowa
you could talk about Tom Tillis in North
Carolina you could talk about the
Arizona question mark for John McCain's
old seat there are people talking about
hey what about getting rid of Mitch
McConnell in Kentucky I think that's an
extreme long shot and I hope I'm not
miss remembering McConnell is up in 2020
I believe if he's not then it's a total
non-starter I'm having a brain glitch
right now and then aside from that but
there's the chance that Democrats lose
that Alabama see that Doug Joe
one in a special election he has to
defend that seed and he barely defeated
a serial accused child sex assault er so
now he has to try to win re-election
there in a very very red state and it is
not looking particularly likely to me so
Ken Democrats take care take control
there
I think it's extraordinarily unlikely so
for me the long-term plan is take the
White House in 2020 keep or extend the
lead in the House of Representatives and
then look for 2022 at taking over the
Senate I haven't even looked at which
seats are up there and often the party
that takes control of the White House
doesn't do so well in that president's
first midterm but those are problems we
can deal with when we get to them in the
immediate win every race we can take in
control of the Senate not looking super
likely for Democrats in 2020 we've got a
great bonus show for you today become a
member
become a patron I'll speak to you then